they fire the guy so there is a video
that went around the internet of a woman
getting out of a the back of the amazon
truck and the amazon hook it up yeah
it's assumed that the amazon worker and
this woman were hooking up
amazon found it and actually fired the
guy watch this
relax relax oh yeah oh yeah would you
have a dog around his shoulder i mean
there was a hanging phone what is wrong
with come on you can't let a man have
some fun [ __ ] off
oh she's barefoot yeah i think she has
her phone in her she's barefoot yeah
there's something over her shoulder no
no it's like no i think it's like that
dress there's two people that were into
each other and they decided to be
naughty in the back of a van i think he
has five for i guess is that frowned
upon yeah
all the fun yeah just let him can can he
get a pass it was two adults who were
just trying to be nice but what what if
he was like dude she came back there to
find a package like prove we had sex by
the way that's what i do yeah it's
soothing you're not allowed to be on the
you know yeah i would assume that people
in there yeah yeah oh i put on her but
dude she jumped in the [ __ ] van
jumped in the van and then fell in like
and then my [ __ ] was all out and i don't
know what happened we were doing some
light wrestling
i like that light wrestling
man they fired him huh yeah amazing good
job too [ __ ] i know someone will help
him out right i'll probably start a
gofundme make more money mm-hmm
that sucks you think maybe they're just
they're dating and they just want to do
something cheeky or or he drops packages
on he's a good looking guy she knows not
her shot she was horny or he shot his
shot one of the two it's weird it's
weird he didn't go into her place of
where she obviously yeah he could yeah
he could have just ran up at her place
like hey got a package i'm not talking
about your [ __ ] amazon package i
guess it's a big dick for you this hand
i know it's having you where where
there's a moment in life where you might
be doing something and you're on your
way somewhere and a girl's there and all
of a sudden you hook up
in your van
your amazon on the job job dropping off
packages you know all right you know
what i mean i think you should be fired
i'm here maybe a warning maybe a warning
how many plumbers or construction guys
are there and there's a lonely housewife
i know guys yeah i know guys you were
like porno are you watching i'm telling
you
he's a stud kind of a brute
and i'm telling you and i can see it
he he goes there he he works and lonely
housewife
it just happened birthday fourth day
fifth day and all of a sudden you're
you're banging yep